were you excited for that mod that was  bringing Red Dead Redemption SMAP into  Grand Theft Auto 5 well I've got some  bad news I'm Tony and this is your  short-lived GameSpot news update the Red  Dead Redemption 5 mod has been cancelled  the team was contacted by take-two after  releasing a trailer and the lead mater  mr. leisurewear has since released a  statement he said I know this is a hard  pill to swallow but as you may have  noticed we did get contacted and we  sadly have to say we are stopping this  project so thanks guys we were all so  happy to see this but it isn't going to  happen  sorry it's definitely a bummer to see  fan projects get shut down but if it's  more red dead you're after  Redemption 2 is slated for ps4 and Xbox  one this fall be sure to subscribe to  stay up to date on that and if you  prefer space to the Wild West then why  not check out our history of Star Wars  Battlefront video  [Music]